okay for people who are joining this
livestream we are here to talk about
virtual machine implementation for
blockchains in wolf language and
unusually for a fact probably the first
time in one of these live streams that
I've done of design meetings I am NOT in
my usual home location I'm off in some
random hotel room as it happens with a
view of the Hudson River in New York
City I think it's not know maybe still
the size of New York I don't even know
some Big River um okay so let's get
started here so the basic idea is to be
able to take for example the messages
that are on the blockchain
and so for example let's say I bring up
let's say I do blockchain
blockchain block data and I look at I'm
just trying to understand what I'm what
I'm able to do here so I'm able to take
this and I say so we're dealing with are
we dealing with Bitcoin are we dealing
with we're dealing with both Bitcoin and
aetherium here is that correct
depends on which face are you in but the
but the virtual machine right now is
only for aetherium
okay fine so I mean the Bitcoin virtual
machine is simpler right well I have to
insist that no one refers to that as a
between their permission I think we have
to first decide what we were what we are
calling a virtual machine if each other
software that runs bytecode we good
called beep going script the machine but
that will mean that we have to call
another type of things are like some
libraries they will be called virtual
machine well yeah lots of things ok so
here this is so where is the where's the
script here
I mean I just picked this random
transaction where is the script input
data byte array is that the script
yeah the binary okay so so there's a
decompiler that we're expecting that
goes from that byte array to some
symbolic representation is that correct
yeah but if you go to the Nobu perhaps
we can show you what else although I
just want to clarify that in theory and
in Bitcoin there's you know
if I look at the analogous thing you
know let's pick this for Bitcoin let's
see how I could probably just say what
do i do I just say transaction is that
correct transaction or a section least
and get a random transaction from there
and change your blocking base to Bitcoin
and there are random choice I could say
take 5 or something ok yes and take that
first one because the person is it going
based in section which with a special
team section don't take the first one
well let me take all of them
if listable you can also so the script
byte array is what we're talking about
here right yeah it's easier to see the
script string to see the op codes okay
so that that is something which has a
sort of what is that brackets all there
that's really that's that's a that's a
flat so you are seeing their signature
and public and that's a flag that tells
some up go what to do but so like this
might be paid to public hash or
something is that right I mean how would
I grow you are seeing this the input
script you're referring to the output
script so if you go a little bit down to
the output you have there there garcina
paid to a script much type script I paid
the public key guys probably around
there too okay so this is a symbolic
version I mean not as symbolic but it's
at least a string version of the script
do we have a similar string version of
the etherium scripts
and not for transaction data okay but
there is a string analog there is a
theorem there's a similar kind of string
yes yes there is okay okay I mean I
might be nice if we had that if we have
a script string for the etherium case -
although clearly the symbolic version is
what we really want
so with that intro let's launch into
what you're talking about here
okay so is this my notes here with these
my notes up here yes yes
okay so then it's something where
there's a virtual machine there's a
state representation of a virtual
machine and there's a specification of
what opcode is being accessed in that
virtual machine and that operates on the
state to give a new state right that's
what I would expect the virtual machine
basically to do yes okay so let's take a
look at what you're talking about here
okay it takes code and human readable
form opcode returns it in byte code form
okay but so from byte code so this is
something where I should be able to take
that function virtual machine from byte
code I should be able to say up here I
should be able to take which one is it I
should that's the etherion blockchain so
I should be able to take that byte array
is that correct yes No
yes okay this bit down yeah and this is
[Music]
up here um and that's my byte array and
I should be able to say virtual machine
from byte code
you
what on earth is that that looks wrong
yeah we still have to support that
directly from the binary if you there's
some example server in your notebook
that what is working right now okay all
right okay so and it will work that way
of course
[Music]
okay all right okay but that's the
that's in principle what happens here so
you know you have you have to set up
functions here the first ones are just
code management as as we mention here
and then we have the how to initialize
the session and evaluate the what you
want in a virtual machine okay by the
way the people on a live stream are
asking about visualization of things
like Merkle trees I mean that's sort of
a thuggin all to what we're talking
about here but I think I mean Christian
has has have you guys been working on
stuff like that we did some experiments
with transactions and visualizing it but
just have some graph for did I say it'd
be nice to have some functions at least
in the function repository that do you
know to visitation I guess I've seen
these kind of mega skyscraper like
visualizations of blockchain activity
which are entertaining but not directly
useful but I would think now that look
Merkle tree thing could be useful right
but that that be civilization you saw
probably required a lot of time
rendering so also when you when you're
trying to make the tree of all the stuff
like real time you will it will take a
bit of time to you to make it so I mean
arguably once we have our own service
fully up and running which is very soon
I think you know caching some some I
mean there is one big Merkle tree isn't
there and I mean if we just cache that
tree and we are able to you know index
in two pieces of it we will be able to
write those tree Frank yeah we can come
up with a way to count something as
specific for that fair enough okay so
all right let's take a look at this okay
what what are these things here I I
don't know enough about these things
these are these are versions of the
etherion virtual machine that's right so
what we support right now is the two
latest ones okay not the current there's
a pseudo opcode or something for the
that specifies which virtual machine is
being used is that correct yes and the
thing is there are some mob codes that
are not valid in some new rob codes for
example that are valid in Peters were
one of them by santim etcetera so that's
why the way we need to have these
different limitations right okay for hey
hold on just one second here
yeah okay go ahead um all right so let's
take a look here okay
I'm not sure that's the right way to do
this I mean when we do Python sub
versions how are we doing that an
external evaluator how we specifying the
Python subversion did you know the
answer does anybody here know the answer
to that that's astonishing yes we only
use this because this is what we do with
blockchain base as well but that's an
Icee Icee so but main net and so on as a
primate fine all right fair enough
okay virtual machine to bytecode I don't
like that either
we didn't either but we weren't sure
what to book well I mean it's a string
virtual machines string to bytecode and
by the way that's not a bytecode I mean
what the bytecode I mean we should say
string two byte array or something
virtual machine string to by terrain
yeah it could be a string gonna be a
list as well on a list of strings yes
fine but I mean I think that that is I
don't know what to call that I mean it's
that assembly language is that you know
what is that um the let's see I mean by
the way some questions are live stream
can we convert the bytes to an assembly
like sequence of op codes to actually
read yeah that's what we're talking
about right now here so can we take for
instance a compile function and send it
to the blockchain yeah well yes that is
we're not quite science fiction but
that's you know we're we're ultimately
hoping to go with this
I mean generating JVM or LLVM byte code
with these functions right so so that is
an interesting question is whether the
LLVM virtual machine you know we want
something general enough that we can
actually give an piece of lrvm code to
this virtual machine function and have
it you know execute LLVM and and i guess
also the JVM we could also do that with
I mean
I guess we have yeah Chevy I'm running
within our infrastructure I don't know
that's an interesting question what what
the state of the JVM would look like
anybody here know that probably the
wrong group to discuss this you know I'm
not sure I'll be a good question to ask
Todd gala he may he may know that okay
so in this case
all right well that's cool program that
leaves in the stack the world population
growth from 1950 to 2019
how come this so few bytes I don't
understand why that why that bytecode is
so little data
what happened to all those people from
1950 to 2019 I don't know Stan this at
least can you expand yes does is it
pushes the number of the population the
stuck in 1950 then pushes the number
from 2019 and then two numbers and
that's the code that will do those
operations okay I understand
so it's like using an old HP calculator
where push
what is the ten mean here 10 bytes okay
okay okay fine so that's literally it
looks very much like the the thing we
saw with Bitcoin here where we have you
know up hash 160 blah blah blah blah
blah right so that's like coats okay
okay all right
okay so let's take a look here then fair
enough I mean I think this is wrong that
it's giving you know it should be a byte
byte array down here but okay yeah
writing this I will green on a name for
a firm for the for these functions not
yet not yet right okay so converting
that top coat okay so there's the
program
so what is this so this is is some some
bytecode that this is a very simple
solidity solely the program that was
compiled in using this ever Amex and so
that we can use this as an example so if
you put all these coding here that's all
the up codes you get using our function
okay okay this third one is a more
complex thing we're just so so how do I
run this code I mean given the state of
the machine at the initial state of the
machine I want to see the steps
associated with running this code
yes that's coming further done okay
there's only like D yeah I get support
functions that's that's what we want to
show you next
okay this last one the brutal machine
code template is just that it seems
useful to have a function that can yeah
there's some contracts as well they're
very usual so we can give the code for
them right so there be an e rc you know
721 or whatever it is with these
parameters and that's like a curated
collection of code templates right
that's the idea with this right now we
have only two or three
well how does it know this so I say this
is you put the type in that Association
okay okay
[Music]
I don't quite understand
and this I mean what's this input type
output type opcodes what is that that
means the filter machine code template
is having its code specified us as
opcode instead of my god that you want
the code generated by it to come out
also us all right so this is the name so
your term opcode is a name for this kind
of string like this sort of human
readable saying that human strings are
usually called up codes in e theorem but
up code is the name for a single one of
these that's an opcode push one as an
opcode right yes so this is more like an
opcode string and among code lists
except okay fine okay this is a part
where you get to three evaluative order
machines okay so
take this I just wanted to see what it
looks like
you
okay instance okay so that's that's
differentiate yes that's what we
finished it between instances the
parameters from your local node and
blockchain state will be the parameters
from the overall blockchain probably the
names could be changed okay so this is
running inside your local instance of
the virtual machine these are
um I don't quite understand this I mean
this is related to this IMAP so your
since you have not specified any special
properties and you're starting with an
empty blockchain mm-hmm
empty blockchain altogether I mean this
isn't something living on the you know a
theory of main net blockchain or
something and I know empty altogether
okay so yes the idea with this is if you
don't specify anything just for example
the theorem and we should be able to
initialize this session with the minimum
amount of of variables set up so that
you can start playing around like in a
sort of sandbox or whatever don't you
want to be unable to initialize the
blockchain as well as initializing this
particular virtual machine then you're
saying that there's a way of
initializing way of starting a
blockchain from nothing right that seems
like a separate problem than starting
this individual instance of the virtual
machine from nothing yeah maybe we could
add that in the example below it shows
how it would you start a blockchain with
some specified characteristics which so
this thing here has what is this is
putting a contract as the only thing
that's on that blockchain that the
Genesis block of that blockchain is this
contract is that right exactly and this
create contract so this is using the
address of force a contract bla and then
it says okay use this create contract
which is an example we generated above
which will just create a you know if we
can get this cleaned up this is a really
terrific thing for the MOOC that you
know the blockchain MOOC that we're
building have you have you been talking
to Johan and so on
to John about this we mentioned yes we
talked about these so well ago I think
this was really important for that I
mean this will really explain to people
you know at the lowest level how they're
organizing their MOOC but you know
somewhere in it people yeah people
people who which would be more more
inclined for technical details would
like to see how this works yes
especially the step-by-step solutions
what do you mean but you mean what when
we can run separate steps okay you're
about to show me this uh-huh we go oh my
god it's complicated
oh yeah it is okay so this is running so
this is an execution trace of this
machine basically is that correct yes
okay since no gas limit or way was
specified it's assumed that is working
with infinity so you can sandbox
what is that so that's a special pseudo
instruction yes just create an
transaction costs cus okay so
gosh okay so the state of the machine
where do I see that it's that result
from the first builder machine evaluate
where is that now that's that's this
result here no no you have to scroll
down a bit
yeah there
I see so there's a blockchain state and
somewhere here there is a
sense the instance will be the state of
that particular variables that carry all
the state stock so in a more general
case if we were doing you know the you
know the Java Virtual Machine or
something we would want probably in this
association we would want something that
says machine state and then we want
something that says global state that
right
in global state in this case would be
the state of the blockchain greatness of
um right um okay let's maybe take a look
um
yeah by the way how are we actually
running I mean the actual implementation
of the etherion virtual machine is that
our own code or is it some standard you
know underlying C code or something no
it's on code how complicated is it and
like 5,000 lines at least like okay how
do we know it's right well I have been
running tests and after now most have
come up and correct but so the reference
implementation of the etherion virtual
machine what is it is it C code yeah I
think that seemed that I could have a
repository for the virtual machine you
see why aren't we why aren't we just
running that C code why don't we just
you know make a WS TP connection to a
program that's just running that C code
so that we know it's you know whatever
bugs it has the same bugs that the you
know standard implementation of DBM has
I think sorry I shouldn't say that I
think you're in a language is go for the
IBM but there are implementations like
in six or seven different languages okay
but ma'am whatever it is
we should be able to run that program in
our system I mean for all the different
blockchains
we should be able to run their virtual
machine program without I mean we
shouldn't try to rewrite all these
virtual machine programs it's a huge
amount of work I mean it's interesting I
suppose it'd be I'd be interesting to
see that code let me see is that what
you just sent me I mean that oh yeah
that's me but of all these attempts so
it's like Petersburg dot M is that an
implementation of the Petersburg
yes that's the Petersburg version oh my
god okay
I mean it's magnificent but I don't
understand why we're doing this I mean
why aren't we just calling the some
standard reference implementation of
this some of this virtual machine
what did I miss here is there some
reason why we need this in top-level
code
I'm not sure I guess is just how it got
done it from the beginning I think this
is the wrong thing I mean I think it's
magnificent
it's interesting it's an interesting
example of code but I think it's the
wrong thing because I think we can't
know this is completely non scalable
right I mean it's very impressive and
that it works is even more impressive
hmm my gosh well okay I mean to me what
I wanted us to concentrate on was the
you know the top level design here
because that's what you know I would
have thought we should just call you
know you just fear not code string into
some you know I assume that these some
see implementations or whatever they are
go implementations take the bite string
a white array and just grind you know
that they can do one step and then give
the results presumably yes I mean should
I look at the github repo for I don't
think so what happens is that the client
usually comes with built on machine
already incorporated and the note just
runs all the transactions that come to
it after synchronizing okay what's this
okay okay I understand
you
right
yeah Carl and I lifestreams pointing out
that there's a Java version of DVM where
we could just use je link to call it
people are also saying that it would be
cool to publish the the welcome language
implementation on github which which we
should probably do because it's it's not
um that's an interesting thing okay but
but the main thing we want to
concentrate on is kind of what it looks
like you know what we were talking about
before what is the basic structure of
you know I think we had a you know a
virtual machine you know virtual machine
execute or something that takes the
Machine spec and then takes the state
and returns a new state yes we used
evaluate because of the really existing
object evaluate yeah that's good I mean
but that okay so that runs a complete
program yeah I don't really know what
theme what you're saying in that case
will be you know program you know that
returns output typically now these
programs on the blockchain what do they
do what is their output or are they
changing or they have side effects on
the global state what's the deal with
that
a yes some context you can change the
state of the blockchain or there's just
a read-only but when they read when when
they when the program finishes does it
have a return value not always its has a
return value only when requested by the
operation by some some operations
okay but so but that return value
something included in the specification
of the instance so that's why the idea
was to return the full state so that's
part of the state of these return body
okay so you're saying machine set spec
program state and then it returns the
state and the state in general could
contain a machine State and a global
State
so the return net values could be in the
machine state well by me I mean the
Machine state could have a program
counter that moves for example right I
mean this this will be either evaluate
one step or evaluate until the program
terminates is that right
aim yes or generate an execution trace
so one could imagine something where
what we're doing is we're saying given
virtual machine evaluate we're saying
ask for a particular property which
could be the final state the the number
of steps it takes to terminate or a
variety of other things right I mean I
think that's some is that right I mean
that that would be the you know that'd
be the type of thing we would expect
there yes that make sense but if we are
calling a and there are implementations
I don't know if they will return all the
values
well might SPECT fine that's the reason
to use ours in those cases but I mean I
think we can have a method option that
says what's implementation to use
so I mean by way of analogy let's look
at um no I think I'd shown this before
um let's see yeah these things as
incredibly minimal virtual machines
register machines okay so
their programs look like this increment
register one decrement register two if
it you know skip on zero I think that is
two instruction one etc so you know in
this case if we had a register machine
here um we would have essentially
machine State goes to register one goes
to blah blah blah might have something
called registers that just is a list of
you know r1 r2 does that make sense and
this has no global state
and then these things here then the
program would be typically something
like so program is presumably always you
know program is a list of opcodes
basically not really opcodes I mean
opcode is the name for you know like you
say the x86 instruction set has this set
of up codes the opcode is a thing that
says like push or a dorm all tore
something like this I don't know what
the name for the whole line is does
anybody know is there a standard name
for the whole kind of thumb you know the
whole line of the program so to speak as
opposed to just the actual opcode you
know in other words every molt is an
instance of a single opcode it's not
that every molt every instance of mult
is something I don't know what its name
is but the melt itself is just is the
thing that's called the opcode I think
well explain that i statement I mean
what a stain and no comment you can call
this OP code plus the arguments that's
what you're saying right yes what were
you calling it a statement or what or a
comment for this program everything is a
script let's see okay fair enough
okay so there is a program is a list of
commands each specified by an opcode
is that a fair statement so I mean what
we could then have is something in
principle where we say you know opcode
arrow molt or something and then
arguments arrow whatever they are
perhaps
alternatively like we've done for web
execute we could conceivably imagine a
shorthand like this
so okay so then let's look at how that
corresponds to what you've got over here
so this is saying so first of all we've
got what is the Machine spec so the
machine spec here is the theory in
Petersberg yes now then we've got
machine State is this thing here so gas
available we can think of as being the
value of what's in a register is that a
true statement I mean it's the gas
available is like like a register like
the content of a register so what I'm
asking them
yeah that's something that it's changing
while it's right well like the contents
of register so is the stack okay so the
memory how is this memory represented
it's an estimate positions the memory
and the value okay so we can see that
happened here okay so it's a 0 original
where a well that's the pointer value is
that correct and this is the content now
the content why isn't the content
integer here is this content in hex or
what yes yes is hex but for our purposes
shouldn't it just be an integer that you
might choose to print out in hex other
words I would expect that what this
would be is that the memory
you know I mean it's a nuisance that
it's a zero origin array but given that
it is you know I would just expect an
integer there you know changed but i
mean we could also for efficient say you
know we could have but i don't know
whether this really matters for this you
know we could have a memory byte array
which is just the compressed version of
this because each one of those is a byte
isn't it each one of the right-hand
sides is a byte it should be a straight
row so you can refer to far parts of
memory I see okay okay fine so that's
that's probably a bad idea so an
association is probably the right idea
because this in this particular case the
memory that's being used is contiguous
yeah but it's not always true right okay
what's this origin color and so on
origin is the original transaction
original address that creating the
transaction and since you can have
contracts that call other contracts and
so on each time you make a new call the
color changes but the origin remains the
same what is the cool a cool is when you
request another contract to be executed
so there was subroutine call yeah it's
like a subroutine yes
okay so effectively then I'm a little
confused here mmm you're saying you're
then getting that in this particular
example you're getting that subroutine
from the global supply of everything
which is the blockchain correct whereas
in a
you know let's say it was a Java program
that would be some separate piece of
code that you have to pull in from
somewhere and it's like if I define f of
X blank kuroneko's whatever I could
refer to that piece of code as F right
and that's that's the kind of thing you
mean here but because there happens to
be in the blockchain world that happens
to be a global source of everything
namely the blockchain you just have to
give the address on the blockchain for
that yes in the Tyrian case yes okay but
more generally we need a way I mean my
gosh we're gonna have to have linkers
and loaders and everything all the usual
stuff at some level because you know in
a sense what what you want to be able to
do is within this one virtual machine
program you want to be able to reference
other virtual machine programs you want
to transfer control to a different
virtual machine program I mean that's
gonna get very complicated and maybe not
something we should be supporting but
here as soon as the you call another
contract you're running code that you're
not seeing here right so you think
you've got a virtual machine that is you
know running this piece of code but
actually it calls some other part of the
blockchain and runs another piece of
code correct right but in this
implementation of course the trace can
go through all the statements that would
be the advantage of having
implementation right I agree that's an
advantage I agree that's a good thing
umm okay all right so these are
essentially special registers the gas
available gas spent and so on is that
true I mean and the stat wouldn't earth
is that stack what is that and that's
all all the opcodes take their arguments
from the stack not from the memory okay
that doesn't really I stuck with were
they open
were they of course great so I
understand but so it just so happens
that that giant big num was just pushed
to the stack is that a slow in this case
the remaining objects from the stack is
that huge number okay but in general
okay so in general that just be a stack
with a which is by the way you know tom
is implementing this new data structure
thing that allows mutable data
structures and you might point out to
him somebody could somebody mentioned to
him stacks I don't know if he has that
on his Lilly probably does have it on
this list but it'd be nice if his data
structure system you know was compatible
with whatever stacks you know
computation stuff is exists here
information to him okay so someone on
our live stream was was saying it'd be
nice if the push-up code was generalized
to just pass an integer so I mean it's
polymorphism for for low-level op codes
it's basically what's being asked for
and I think that that's a level of kind
of symbolic representation that we
haven't quite got to here I mean that's
certainly something that I mean that
requires compilation and code analysis
to go from the generic push-up code to
the particular one that you should be
using to the data structure that
actually occurs at that stage in this
particular program um yeah someone's
good pointing out it might be time for
sparse byte array I don't quite think
we're ready for that yet and I don't
think the
um I agree that it would be a gosh
that's an interesting I mean in in you
know if you take a core dump or
something and you're analyzing it I can
see that there's some value to having a
sparse byte array for core dump analysis
but I think that's a that's a future
adventure um Karl is pointing out that
states based models and the things that
we have in the microcontroller kit are
in some sense also virtual machines and
Brian is asking how would you validate
your transaction before calling its code
so I mean don't we have a know we have a
you can set up a blockchain transaction
right and then you and then you simply
sign the transaction and make it happen
right I mean that that's not a um what
am I trying to say the but validating
it's a question of what the validation
you know what what does it mean to
validate a transaction what properties
do you want to be true of a given
transaction that's the interesting thing
where you're essentially defining a
computational contract for what should
be true about that transaction and that
is indeed what we would like to be able
to do with these virtual machine
simulations is be able to say given that
we want this property is that true for
this particular contract and I mean for
that ultimately so I mean you know an
example of a stretch question is can we
make one of these things symbolic that
is is it conceivable that we could say
the input to a virtual machine is just X
and that we could get out here a piece
of code or for that matter an
essentially mathematical expression that
represents the operation of that virtual
machine on input called X did that make
any sense like what happens when you
know if I turn one of those literal
operands into a symbolic operand can I
have some
symbolic representation of what's going
on which is what I thought you know
because that's where if we're going to
do validation and theorem proving that's
what we have to operate on I can
presumably that like that Isabelle
implementation of the EVM presumably is
something which has some kind of
symbolic representation on which a
theorem prover can run did I lose
everybody or did everybody kind of um
reaction to that hello anybody there
oops our here I think we were just
processing what you just said
okay but I mean I I think yeah we're
pretty much out of time for this
particular meeting but look I think
there's several things we really need to
look at we really need to look at what's
involved in simply hooking up existing
you know virtual machine implementations
what's involved you know kind of
cleaning up this interface here I think
it's clearly useful I mean for example I
would have thought that some of these
earlier things that you had here like
virtual machine to bytecode I mean I'm
kind of wondering whether those are
import/export functions whether you know
you're simply taking the symbolic
representation and saying exported as a
such-and-such string
I think well okay fair enough I mean
this is basically I mean basically what
you're talking about here is something
like come you know it's basically
virtual machine encode or compile
I don't know virtual machine encode
virtual machine decode something like
that I don't know what deco does I mean
I think that's supposed to go from the
machine code to some decompiled form
that will go to their lease toss things
but but which we really would like to be
symbolic not just a list of strings I
mean in a perfect world what we would
have is something that says you know
opcode um you know push or something
I don't know well we could call it
virtual machine that's just the
shortness save VM operation and then
it's push and then it's the operands
and you know the goal here is to make it
be the case that we could say you know
something like this and we could say
literally X
why six and that then we would be able
to have something which says you know I
don't know what it is VM resolve or
something which turns that into six XY
in the case where we can do that because
their cases were and that's obviously
something we can't get from that's
something we have to implement for
ourselves we can't you know that's a
reason to have a top level or from
language implementation because it's
capable of being symbolic right and
presumably the code you've already got
there could perfectly well be fed
symbolic inputs and if I take a look at
that code um it array has the infinity
for example yes I mean so this so that's
an exciting thing that becomes possible
with this code I mean that's a you know
I don't know whether it's been fully you
know symbolic hardened
but we'll clean that up enough so equal
work symbolically right and again you
know what I would expect is that the
program is represented by some sequence
of symbolic operations and that then
there are rules that are you know
feasible to the theorem prover that say
things like a push and a pop you know is
equivalent to the identity or something
am I making sense and then you know that
becomes essentially the definition of
the operation of the machine again I
would assume that that's what that
Isabel version has in it is a set of
essentially assertions about the
operation of the machine from which you
can prove theorems about the machine
that's what I would anticipate um right
anyway I think we will need this form of
full stream because that's the way that
people writes the programs and so we
should I mean listen clearly what we
need to be able to do is you find some
random byte array on the etherion
blockchain or for that matter the
Bitcoin blockchain you say what is this
and you say here's the symbolic
representation of it and let me run it
on some sample inputs okay great here's
what the execution trace looks like or
alternatively let me run it on symbolic
inputs and see oh yes this thing I mean
it may not resolve it may be something
where what the thing is doing is
computing three random numbers and you
know sending your fortune to you know
you know random people on the blockchain
chosen by those random numbers maybe I
don't know so by the way a point being
made by a Brian on the live stream is
that that one would need to name
transactions and you know one would need
to have a symbolic a notion of symbolic
code blocks so for example if you say
at this moment we call the thing at
address F on the blockchain let me not
use F s so we're out of a hexadecimal
zone you know address u1 the blockchain
then address you would be a symbolic
function that you know we say and then
then it's basically just you of whatever
arguments it is represents the and
that's not resolved yet and so for
example when we have a theorem proving
it could be that with our predicate
logic theorem prover that it could be
well I don't care what that what you is
because you know what appears is you
appears in a way that's factorable out
from the from the operations and so on
but anyway look I mean I think the thing
we need to do is you know you've got a
good start on the overall framework I
think the details and implementation I
think a huge amount of work was spent
here on getting a top level of language
implementation of EVM I think if we can
make it symbolic it's super cool and
very useful I think though that the
original brief of this project couldn't
have been executed just with you know
outside implementations of these block
chains and I suggest that we get a
pipeline for how to do that then I
suggest that we I mean we should do this
as an experiment for register machines
and Turing machines and things like that
um to just check that the formalism we
have actually works for those and
they're going to be a lot simpler they
don't have gas prices and things in them
they just have values of registers or
the state of the tape and the state of
tape is obviously the analog of what
you've got with memory and memory
locations and notice that the way we're
representing you know in in the Turing
machine function we're representing this
the tape and it's a little bit tricky
because in that case it's a doubly
infinite tape which probably in some
world could be represented by it's the
pair of location with 0 in the middle
you know from minus infinity to infinity
we're choosing to represent it as a 1
origin you know array that doesn't have
extensibility on the left so to speak
but I think you know that would be using
that to represent what you're calling
memory here is reasonable I think that
we've probably got other simple models
where I mean you know a trivial stack
machine should also be represented with
one of these virtual machines things so
I mean I think we've got three types of
virtual machines that we care about
we've got the very idealized virtual
machines like register machines Turing
machines and so on we've got the the
very kind of every you know practical
everyday like LLVM like JVM those kinds
of things where presumably they're state
I mean I don't know how many of those
things run in enough of a sandbox that
there aren't external i/o interrupts and
things like that that have to be
represent it um and then and then
finally we've got this sort of hybrid
case of the blockchain virtual machines
which are kind of a little bit of a
hybrid between these very low-level
theoretical things and these very
high-level kind of fully functional LLVM
JVM type things so I mean all of these
we want to be part of what we represent
as virtual machine of course there's a
there's a an even more ambitious thing
which we're not doing yet but one day we
might which is to take an actual VM of
the kind that you know we deliver wool
from engine and a you know in a I don't
know you know in a in a an actual um oh
I don't remember you know the the kind
of the brand names of the VMs but an
actual official complete VMware where
it's only interaction with the outside
world is being poked through you know
its various network connections and so
on I mean that would be it will be nice
to get our formalism here to have the
possibility that that VM could
essentially represent a remote kernel
did that make sense would registry key
everybody out everybody is totally
freaked out so it makes sense at least
with the real machine for a virtual
machine full of mention is a
I mean that's a you know I I guess see
the difference is that you know when you
have a wolf in language session there is
implicitly a state of the machine
there's a state of the session we don't
usually explicitly show you that because
it's like you're defining variables and
it's like okay they go off and they're
they're defined but we could imagine
actually it would be quite useful and
probably we already have this formalism
for some of our sandboxes I bet we do
of something which just represents this
is the whole state of the world from
engine virtual machine right so in other
words you've defined I mean so what is
the state of the virtual machine the
state of that virtual machine is
basically the values were a bunch of
variables
that's dump of asterisks all the context
yeah that's right that's that's the but
I mean in a in a pure version of that
it's just I mean the the thing that's
awkward is that you might hope that the
that the Wolfram language whorfin engine
is sort of an immutable thing and that
then its operating on the state that
simply is an association so I mean you
know essentially we've got the you know
this is the wolf mansion VM and what we
would have here is something where the
state is you know X goes to well
probably it has to be a string but the
you know it might be you know symbol
values and it's things like you know X
goes to whatever it goes to etc etcetera
and so what we could imagine here is
then just running you know it's a little
bit
because at each point the wolf mansion
runs to a fixed point so it takes the
state of the world and whatever that
state is it just it iterates that state
until it reaches a fixed point and the
way that normally in a session the way
you're going to the next fixed point is
you're adding input and saying okay go
take this to a fixed point and I suppose
the same is true with even the EVM right
that you're starting off from some state
and it's just gonna run until it gets to
a fixed point that true where it runs
until it has executed the program it's
finished so to speak yes and and then
the way it gets activated again is on
the blockchain the way it gets activated
again is somebody puts some new thing
onto the blockchain which might
potentially recall that piece of code
right so in other words like one of our
sessions where somebody is putting new
input into the wolfram engine and then
that's you know sort of you know sort of
iterating and getting getting results so
similarly um what you're looking at here
is the thing yeah okay well this is
interesting I mean I think we've got
some distance to go I think I mean I
guess you guys understand the vision for
what this virtual machine function you
know which again I see I see what I see
what people will do as being things like
this you know define a register machine
you know we've got a register machine
definition now and we might have
multiple kinds of register machines and
now you know there's the toy problem of
proof of theorem about the register
machine then the next level up is given
the EVM you know prove a theorem about
that or in some of these other things I
mean I could imagine you know we had a
very efficient implementation of this
this is a perfectly sandbox I mean we
would love it if a bunch of other
languages had a virtual machine that was
encapsulated like this because then we
could run them you know we
safely run them they have no side
effects all the state is represented in
the actual Association that comes out of
the execution of the virtual machine all
right
well to be continued I think this is a
this was a kind of a kickoff discussion
of the virtual machine world but maybe
you guys can have a think about this and
see what you know see what some quick
paths to implementing some of this stuff
are yeah
so also you see has to change to this
machinist state and global state or name
so they can be in a license right I
think I I'm suggesting that yes but I'm
not going through the full naming
sequence because I think that these are
you know this type of stuff I kind of
think that you see for example when you
say virtual machine to bytecode I mean
like Turing machines have a you know
weird specification you know 1s you know
whatever it is I don't know you know
there's a there's a compact
representation of Turing machines that's
often used and I think that that is
something we would probably want to
support just like we have a I mean you
know actually the other case the other
case that we should support is finite
state machines
I mean that's the you know we're
essentially it's a regular expression
that's being given or a graph where
where that starts from a reg X or a
graph and we're essentially we've got a
you know virtual machine evaluate again
this all requires thought and you know
we need to have a formalism that will
work you know for a finite state machine
where you've just got um and again I'm
not completely sure about the way that
that evolves to fix points and all those
kinds of things anyway very interesting
stuff this is a beginning have a think
let's talk about it again in a little
while
sounds reasonable yes make sense okay
thank you all thanks to folks on the
livestream and see you later